[Applause]
nobody did it quite like Vivian Westwood
commanding the catwalk with an air of
decadence and theater the Grand Dame of
British fashion who influenced
generation after generation breaking
boundaries along the way
punk of course is Central to the
westward Legend while working as a
teacher she met Malcolm McLaren together
they created a look and a sound that
would redefine music and culture by the
early 1970s they had a shop on London's
place to be seen the Kings Road where
many say Punk was born
McLaren managed the Sex Pistols while
Westwood created their iconic image
influencing millions of young people she
had a astonishing talent that McLaren
amongst others spotted quite early on to
see what other people could not see see
the possibility of making out of things
that other people wouldn't think to make
out of and that happy Fusion really is
some of what uh begat the look of punk
which arguably McLaren and Vivian
Westwood are responsible for
Vivian Westwood was born into an
aspirational working-class family in
1941. her early love of making her own
clothes in post-war austerity Britain
never left her
often she worked in her own small flat
in London and when punk became more
mainstream in the 1980s Westward fell
out of love with it to create a
romanticized look which would influence
pop culture
and while her later collections saw her
become established on the global fashion
scene she never became part of the
establishment
her designs influenced by art and
literature always had an edge
Vivian Westwood was never shy about
being openly political fashion became
her platform for Dissent she used her
status to commit to a range of issues
from the WikiLeaks founder Julian
Assange to climate change and fracking
but it's her contribution to punk and to
fashion for which she will be remembered
best as a Pioneer who broke the mold